you're turning the pages in a very
strange and very nice thing dawns on you
this book gets you obviously the author
who might have died centuries back never
knew you at all
but they write as if they did it's as if
you'd confess your secrets to them and
then they'd gone off and written this
work around what you told them
transformed of course into a story about
people with different names or into an
essay that doesn't cite your case
explicitly but might as well do because
it's so completely on target we never
quite feel we're understood well enough
even by the people who we genuinely like
and who are emotionally attached to us a
permafrost of loneliness often persists
just below the surface even when things
are broadly speaking going well enough
all this the book that understands you
appears to know and to be able to
correct the book in question might be
one that speaks to millions like the
Harry Potter series or it could be an
almost unique discovery of your own
perhaps Sheila's letters on the
aesthetic education of mankind written
at the very end of the 18th century with
its haunting efforts to fuse a noble
idealism with political realism it could
be a self-help book about sex that
alights on just the things that are
troubling you or you might feel that
Mademoiselle d'amour bar written by
tear-filled Gucci in the middle of the
nineteenth century and which tells the
story of a man and a woman who are both
in love with central character the opera
singer Madeleine de mapa was written by
historical miracle exactly for you a
book knows you by pinpointing and taking
very seriously a major but often ignored
problem that happens to be looming in
your existence for instance when Harry
Potter is with the Dursleys the feeling
of being an alien in a familiar
environment for long stretches of time
harry has to live around people who have
no idea of his real nature they never
acknowledge his actual strengths he's
regarded as a contemptible freak for
things that elsewhere would make him
popular and important the book is hugely
alive to the feeling of not being
appreciated with many books we're
pleased because we encounter sympathy
for things that deserve generous
treatment but normally don't get it the
darker aspect of one's characters are
getting a tender hearing you've been
heard you've heard others and
book says I know so often despite all
the people around us we're lonely and
ashamed
we're haunted by the worry that no
reasonable person could feel anything
but derision or contempt for our
problems we fear that to share them with
our friends would lead to bewildered
rejection a book that understands you is
like an ideal parent or friend who makes
it acceptable to suffer in the way we do
our weirdest sorrows or enjoyments are
recast as valid parts of human
experience which can be met with
sympathy and kindness it is even though
the relationship is with paper and ink
only a kind of love and perhaps one of
the deepest kinds of love will ever know
you